there's an anti pornography group called
enough is enough and they've released a
press statement where they said that
Donald Trump has pledged to effectively
ban porn if elected president president
Trump signed a pledge distributed to all
of the presidential candidates by this
group enough is enough called quote the
children's Internet safety presidential
pledge and it frames porn sort of as
something inherently tied to the
exploitation and endangerment of
children and the pledge itself makes it
sound sort of like all porn not not just
child porn that all porn is dangerous to
the well-being of children and enough is
enough says that obscene porn and child
porn are not protected under the First
Amendment now we already have laws in
place that prevent and punish the sexual
exploitation of children but this pledge
that Donald Trump has signed according
to this release by enough is enough
suggests that all obscene porn that's
not a term that's explicitly defined so
what is even met by obscene porn should
receive the same legal treatment as
child pornography for example if you
know let's say Louis was into something
where like Magic the Gathering is played
in the context of pornography if
somebody said oh that's obscene it would
effectively be treated just like child
porn which seems a little crazy to me
Louis for the party that says oh
actually we want small government yeah
I'll be damned if I'm arrested for that
that's bad in the press release that
they released enough is enough mentioned
that Democratic nominee Hillary Clinton
has not signed this pledge actually
Hillary Clinton basically doesn't sign
pledges as far as I understand the idea
of banning porn porn is is pretty absurd
in and of itself if no laws are being
violated how do you justify banning porn
and of course what counts when you say
well anything obscene will be banned is
nc-17 movie content obscene what about
simulated sexual acts or what about
whatever we can come up with whatever
example we sort of want here but there's
actually a bigger issue I mean we have
it pretty clear that the idea of just
banning porn is incredibly subjective
because what even really qualifies but
it actually exposes some pretty
significant hypocrisy from Donald Trump
because Trump was number one interviewed
in Playboy magazine years ago which
suggests that he's at least generally
okay with that type of nudity in
magazines is that porn well modern Oh
depends how you define it I guess
Trump's own wife Melania Trump has
appeared nude in magazines and has
posted intimately with other women it's
possible possible that trumps own wife
was in content that the group enough is
enough would want made illegal if the
ban that Trump pledged to try to force
actually happened if Trump were to be
President of the United States genuinely
and patently ridiculous Louis yeah it's
this is I wonder what other emissions
they have maybe this is the only mission
but I just don't understand this battle
this is like what we talked about in
Utah there's this huge campaign they say
that this is destroying that the fabric
of America things like that I mean I
honestly I would say that rhetoric like
there's and and Donald Trump's rhetoric
is what's destroying the fabric of
America well you know what's also the
common thread through all of this that
everything is for the kids it's to
protect the kids is what we hear from
the moral Crusaders we can't have gay
marriage because it's dangerous to
children we can't have a trans bathroom
policy that lets people use the bathroom
for the for the gender they identify
with because it would be dangerous to
children and every single one of these
arguments ignores that we already have
very extensive laws that protect
children from any kind of assault in a
bathroom regardless of what gender the
bathroom is designated from etc etc etc
it's always protect the kids and it's
sort of smart because people do react to
that it just makes absolutely no sense